はい、はやく！
はやく、はやく！
いいよ、持ってかない持ってかない！
はやく、はやく！はやく！
（友人：Switch持ってかない？）
はやく！はやく、はやく、はやく！
やばいって、来る途中…！
あぁーっ！！
（あぁーーっ！！）
はい、というわけで緊急事態です
静岡駅にフリーザーが出ました
フリーザーが出て
あの、あともう10分ぐらいしかないんで
ちょっと、本当にスピード勝負から
（マジですか！）
いや、本当に行くしかない！
（マジで！）
（あと10分もいないよ）
え、まじでそれぐらい
なんだっけ、最近アップデートされたんだよね、確か
（えぇーっ！なにそれ？）
待ってアップデート動きすらしないんだけど
（やばいっすね）
は？は？は？は？は？
え待って、むりむりむり
「ジョニーデップのお宝」っていうやつ？
（そうそうそう）
3色あるじゃん、チームが
あれの青の貢献度が1番高かったからフリーザーらしい
（なるほどね）
うん
もう僕急ぎすぎて
（ははははっ！）
はっ！
は？なんかログイン外れてんだけど
よし行こう！
【はじめ急ぐ】
はやく！
【はじめ走る】
駿府城公園
（え？）（は？）
1時半まで
とりあえず静岡駅にいるやつが
どうなったか知りたい、電話で聞くわ
これでもしだってさあ
行く意味ないじゃん、いなかったら
（そうだね、まじ無駄）
【電話の呼出音】
もしもし？
（電話：お疲れ様です）
おつかれー
ねえ、もう静岡駅のやつって
もういなくなっちゃった？
（静岡駅のやつは今終わりました）
え！！
（終わったww）
次、駿府城公園？
（電：1時半までいるらしいんで）
分かりました！直ちに！
直ちに向かいます！
はやく、はやく！
（待って、待ってよ！）
（え、りょうくん大丈夫？）
【ﾋｭｩｩｩｩｩｩｩｩｩﾝ[車の効果音]】
フリーザーが出ました
CP 37603
全員でこいつのHPかな？
なんかそれを削り切ると捕まえれる的な？
分かんないんですけど
ねえ、ちょっと近いうちに取りに行きます
ごめんちょっとフリーザーがいるから
ごめんね、はい
あれっぽくね？スマブラのあの人
（あっ、俺が使ってる！）
そそそ！
ベヌ、ベヨネッタだ！
（ベヨネッタww）
（化粧したら絶対に…）
完全にベヨネッタじゃん
いくぞー！
待って！
ゼニガメじゃね、あれ？
（どこ？）
スイ、待って、スイクンスイクン！
（動いてる、動いてる！）
待って、スイクンスイクンスイクン！
わあああ、バカかバカか！
おい捕まるぞ！
時間ないって！
うわあ、やばい人が
捕まえま
もうはじ、これもう始まる説？
まじ逃げたい
あと10秒
始まっちゃった始まっちゃった
【フリーザーの鳴き声】
ああああああああ
あ、あ、あ、
待ってなになに
待って、マグカルゴあなたは何してるの
（もうずっとタップしてください）
（え、なんでなんで避けなくていいの？）
こう？こう？
待って、バンギラス多くない？
【レイドバトル早送り】
倒した、倒した！
え？え？
（コングラッチュレーション）
コングラッチュレーション？
あああ！
（げんきのかけら5個）
（わざマシンノーマル）
ななななな？
うおおおお！
（うおおやべえ！）
【はじめ興奮】
（待って待って！むりむりむり）
これ捕まえればいいんでしょ？
（むりむりむり！）
外した！
（あああああ！）
待ってすごい激しい！
あと何個？あと何個？
（あと3、あと4個あと4個）
（ねえ当たりすらしない）
あ、待ってきたきた！
こいこい、待って
待って、頼む頼む
まっ、まああ！
え、無理だ無理だ無理だ
（無理じゃん、絶対無理じゃんこんなの）
えー、どんどん無駄にした
どんどん無駄にしたよ
待ってすごい
（逃げないけど）
待ってこれさあ
俺あとラストじゃない？これ
【ボール外れる】
ねえ、だめだった
（まじ最悪なんだけど）
もう会えないの？
（あもう無理だ、おわった）
もう会えない？
（1日1回？でも明日もある？）
でも俺、3個ぐらいすごいさあww
それがあれば、それがあれば
え？ は？は？は？
（え？え？は？は？）
おいおいおい！
（400円あるから4枚は買える）
え終わったじゃん俺の夏
（もう行こ行こ）
もう帰ろうぜ
もう終わったじゃん
ねえ待ってもう無理、じゃあいないってこと？
え？
（まじ？）
え？フリーザーですか？
今ですか？
あ、城北公園？分かるよ
たぶんあっちの
（向こうだ向こう向こう）
【はじめ焦る】
ﾓｳ!ｶﾞﾏﾝﾃﾞｷﾅｲ!!ｶﾞﾏﾝﾃﾞｷﾅｲ!!
【はじめ走る】
【ﾋｭｩｩｩｩｩｩｩｩｩﾝ[車の効果音]】
（誰か：移動ですか？）
一応あっちに行こうと…
そこで人がいたら
（そっちでやっちゃう？）
いなかったら戻ってきます
（いや…）
あっ、じゃあいたらまた来ましょうか？
（そこまでしなくても…）
1回じゃあ来ますね、状況見て
（気をつけて）
ありがとうございます
（誰か音頭とって）
じゃあ僕行きます
えーー
フリーザーまだの方？
フリーザーまだの方今から行きまーす！
（はい）（はい）
フリーザー行きまーす！
（はーい）
2人！？
（4人）
（11人です）
結構ありじゃない？
あ、倒した？
やったーー！
え、これで捕まえればいいんでしょ？
（まじ無駄に…）
わかった
絶対、確実にいく！
（ちょちょちょ、なんで投げてないんすか）
（確率低くします）
（きんズリきんズリ）
下ネタみたいに言わないで…
（言ってない言ってない…）
どうどうどう、どう？
（いい、いいよ）
（いいよ、これで捕まってくれたら）
（1,2…）
えええ？
【ED】
ルギア戦です
ちょっと、これはモノにしたいところではある
えっえっえっ…
1,2,…
さあぁーーん！！
【はじめ興奮】
捕まえた！
（ずるいーー！）
よっしゃぁーー！
でたでたでた！